الان من داخل باريس ومعنا ايضا من هناك
مراسل العربيه فاديه الدهوك انقل لنا
المشهد من عندك ما الذي يحدث
اهلا ميسون التظاهره ما زالت مستمره هي
بدات قرابه الساعه الثانيه بعد ظهر اليوم
في شوارع العاصمه باريس وهي تسير الان نحو
وجهتها الاخيره سوف تسير مسافه نحو 4
كيلومترات حتى تصل الى الوجهه الاخيره كما
ترون هناك حشود غفيره جدا من المتظاهرين
نزلت الى الشارع اليوم تلبيه لدعوه ثمان
نقابات عماليه وايضا نحو 20 منظمه طلابيه
المتظاهرون كما ذكرتي يعترضون بالدرجه
الاولى على رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
وهذا اليوم هو يوم حاسم جدا لان هناك جلسه
مسائله للحكومه حول مشروع القانون هذا
تجري الان في البرلمان وايضا هناك تصويت
مجلس الشيوخ حيث يدرس الان بنود هذا مشروع
القانون هذا حتى يتم اما التصويت عليه
والموافقه او عودته الى مجلس النواب لكي
تعود المداولات من البدايه
حسب حسب ما فهمت في بعض التعديلات يمكن ان
تقرر اليوم ولا لا
هناك تعديلات كثيره قوى اليسار المعارضه
لهذا المشروع بالدرجه الاولى طرحت الاف
التعديلات الاف التعديلات على نصوص وبنود
هذا القانون ايضا هناك تعديلات تناقش في
مجلس الشيوخ لكن حتى الان لا يوجد معلومات
ان كانت هذه التعديلات سوف تمر من من
المستبعد ان يتمكن مجلس النواب او حتى
مجلس الشيوخ من التوافق على هذه التعديلات
لتهدئه الامور الحكومه ما زالت مصره على
السير قدما في هذا القانون والمعارضه
تطالبها بالاستماع اليها والى صوت الشارع
يقولون ان هذا اليوم هو يوم لاغلاق فرنسا
لاصابه
الاقتصادم الشلل
عذرا لضيق الوقت فادي بدي افهم شو اللي عم
بيصير على الارض ايضا في اشتباكات وحجم
هذه الاشتباكات ولماذا
[موسيقى]
في التظاهر الفارسيه الموكب الباريسي يسير
بشكل سليم حتى الان هناك بعض الموانا
المناوشات المحدوده جدا بين المتظاهرين او
بين عدد من الشبان الذين يعرفون بانهم
متطرفون من قوى اليسار مجموعات شابه حذرت
الشرطه من انهم سوف يكونون سوف تكون
اعدادهم نحو 400 شخص ايضا هناك مواجهات
بين الشرطه والمتظاهرين اندلعت في مدينه
ليون وسط وجنوب فرنسا في وقت سابق اليوم
لكن حتى الان الامور هادئه نسبيا نوعا ما
والمناوشات محدوده جدا لكن كيف ستتطور
ستتطور الامور لا نعلم هناك انتشار امني
كثيف جدا الاف عناصر الشرطه منتشرين في
الشوارع اليوم هناك مساله مهمه ان هذا
الاضراب اثر على قطاع الطاقه هناك اخبار
وردت قبل قليل بانقطاع التيار الكهربائي
عن احدى المناطق في او عن احدى المدن في
منطقه بادوكالي وهناك نحو 1500 شخص في هذه
المنطقه الان يعيشون من دون تيار ك وكل
ذلك بسبب اضراب الموظفين في محطات التوليد
عن العمل اليوم الاضراب الذي اثر على حركه
المواصلات كما ذكر النقل والطيران صح جدا
في حركه المواصلات بين بريطانيا
قطاع النقل والطيران
المدن التي تاثرت بشكل كثير او الخطوط بين
فرنسا وبريطانيا هي اكثر المناطق التي
تاثرت بهذا الاضراب هناك
هيئه الطيران المدني دعت شركات الطيران
الى الغاء ما بين نحو 20 الى 30% من رحلات
الطيران اليوم في مطار شال دوغول وايضا في
مطار اورلي اليوم وغدا الاربعاء